[Music]
so i wanted to talk about this because
[Laughter]
hot news from barney's beatery
[Laughter]
no there's a it's actually a new york
thing oh
yeah pasadena new york
in new york yeah there's a surveillance
video from a manhattan subway and it
shows a good samaritan woman trying to
stop a thief from stealing another
woman's phone oh and i just want to
[ __ ] with all the bad [ __ ] happening
everywhere yeah we just got to give it
up to this lady for stepping in trying
to stop the thief yeah was she like
these and then someone went yay and she
went
you can watch it right here here we go
but
i wanted to honor her because she ended
up getting stabbed by trying to help
she's alive and recovering but yeah dude
yeah right before you watch it right at
the end by the way she got stabbed but
so this is the thief he tries to jack a
phone oh she just even hesitated
oh oh
she got stabbed in the leg right there
that's why she's hopping oh dude that's
great but he dropped the phone
still doing it like while she's stabbed
in the leg yeah so he already had like a
knife out or like easy access to it [ __ ]
you got to watch it bro
hold on please
so he he did the thing where like i
guess this is a thing if you're just on
your phone sitting and if people just
knock it out your hand first rather than
grab it and then they'll try to pick it
up and what he was doing he's trying to
pick it up and she just got all in his
way at him she tripped them yeah she
tripped him and then he just shanked her
in the leg like and ran away wow yeah
easy access to a knife like that huh but
that is some like dope ass [ __ ] to like
do that for someone because we see in
the comments of every one of these
videos of assault is someone saying guy
like me i would have [ __ ] stopped
them around this and it's a lot of
people can say that [ __ ] but
now she can really be that commentary
yeah
she could actually go i would have done
something not me because i know those
fools got knives out and [ __ ]
but that is some like that's some really
cool [ __ ] she didn't even hesitate that
was like instinctual no i'm in i'm i'm
there with my whm xm4s noise canceling
headphones
i got knife cancelling headphones yeah
i'm like i see it happen i'm like
is that the new york way of
dude like dude someone like anything
could happen so anything crazy can
happen in the subway people like mind
their business what's one of the
craziest things you've seen in the
subway someone jumped the the turn like
nah like the re um
the tracks someone jumped from track to
track just for fun like i don't know
like someone was recording him he ran
jumped made it on the other side no one
was even knowingly even cared wow
oh there's also a viral video of some
guy like threatening to jump on the
tracks and kill himself at like rush
hour and all you hear is people in the
back groaning like oh my god don't do it
on this train
over there
you're getting in the way bro do that
[ __ ] somewhere else like you hear that
[ __ ] in the back like people so they
don't want to be late to work yeah they
don't even care if he dies
yeah dude like there's like that video
of just someone trying to like
threatening to do it like i'm gonna jump
like oh my god there's someone on the
tracks okay yeah cause i'm sure that
happens pretty frequently right yeah so
with these statistics robberies up 72
percent 72. do you feel like you see
that
like yourself when you're in new york do
you like notice that shit's a little bit
like crazier at all not really well i
mean it probably happens where you can't
see it you know like in the subway at
night you know
i usually at night i'm ubering now
because of the
the subways like the subway shooting i'm
like i'm not catching the subway
but i i don't know i definitely don't
really notice anything i guess it's just
out of sight
but yeah cause it yeah yeah it's like in
ninja turtles where they passed the
wallet in the beginning nobody knew dude
the whole city the tv
where'd it go oh yeah
i mean it's the shredder you're not
going to [ __ ] see it rokusaki man
that guy
have you been hearing like like just out
of new york like more ship and going
down and whatever because we've been
hearing it here in l.a
and then like you hear like certain
people close to you got like jacked or
something happened to their store or
whatever but then yeah i've been hearing
just well like with the asian hate stuff
like it's starting to get like one like
twice removed of like my friend's aunt's
friend got whacked or something so it's
getting closer and closer yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like one of the one of the
like i forget who it was but it was like
an old asian guy like he was like a shop
owner or something he just got like
assaulted and that was like my friend's
uncle oh no
so it's like it's starting to be like
really close to home yeah i'm like oh
[ __ ] it's getting closer and closer
because it's happening so much yeah yeah
stats right now are crazy for new york i
mean i feel like
i see the effect here in l.a
well you're in hollywood which is like
closer to l.a i'm always either in
hollywood or downtown and those are the
two places that have like the they got
two of the best problems like
you know what i mean my mom had an
incident and she got it she avoided it i
think did i tell it on here before
i think so i told you guys about that
right yeah she wasn't she was in a pokey
place
and she saw this homeless dude walk in
and he kept like eyeing my mom and she
was like yo this [ __ ] tripping
he like reached out for her and she like
ducked under him
ran out and he started chasing her
oh and then she went to a couple across
the street that was like getting in
their car and then as soon as he was
chasing her he saw that she went to the
couple he walked down the street across
the street and went the other way
and i was like damn she the fact that
she avoided that she's trying to like
rock so he tried to attack her in the
restaurant in the restaurant and nobody
didn't do champions in their restaurant
and this this is this was in like south
pasadena damn it was like a considered a
nice area yeah so i don't know it's
crazy you gotta be vigilant what do you
think of mayor eric adams
oh that's the that's the cop mayor dude
that dude's all nypd you know nypd is
like the 11th biggest army in the world
or some [ __ ] what they need a lot of
they have a huge staff huh i feel like
he hasn't been in office long enough to
see if he's good or not yeah i thought
new york was all about the whole defund
the police and they don't yeah but then
they got this guy and he's like so he's
the opposite four cops yeah interesting
or maybe they were defunding and then
they saw the results of that so they
flipped the other way well now i mean
there's still crazy [ __ ] going on right
now with all the cops yeah yeah so i
mean yeah i don't think he's been in
office long enough for us to really
understand the effects of his policy
but the only thing has been just the
excessive amount of cops in the subway
but then like there's still being crime
there's more cops but more crimes
there's also a lot of people too
there's like a big concentration of
people too it's hard to catch everybody
i thought during covert a lot of people
left new york they're like we're going
to florida a lot then people are coming
back though if new york has the l.a
problem it's not even the cops it's the
da if they're getting like re-let go so
for us it's the cops are doing their job
but then once they are supposed to get
prosecuted they get let out so the cops
are like picking up the same people over
and over oh and so it's kind of hard to
stop they never stay in jail yeah the
cops are stopping the crime it's just
that the same criminals are getting let
out and the stats get all [ __ ] up too
because of no prosecution then it
doesn't so they go hey we're doing no
crime exactly so then whoever's getting
getting the political benefit of doing a
good job yeah but like but my restaurant
got broken into four times there is
crime right now it's on a technicality
dude definitely yeah so this woman who
uh was a good samaritan they don't know
her name
right so whoever she is
good [ __ ] wow call her nameless
we'll call her one of the states we'll
call his tabitha
are there any crime fighters in new york
do you remember when in portland ninja
turtles no the portland remember when
there was a uh real there was a real
[ __ ] crime fight something phoenix
dark phoenix yeah he was like an mma
fighter some [ __ ] oh because they have a
mutual combat law
but the cops were trying to find him too
to like stop him from doing that yeah
he had like homies too like he started
creating like the avengers of it
whatever happened wait that vigilante
stuff i'm like y'all just sit around
waiting for crime yeah you know like how
does that happen at least spider-man can
swing around like you're taking phoenix
that's his name
phoenix jones and they're like that's a
good insurance policy it must be crazy
expensive
he was an mma guy but if anyone came up
to you in a costume like that i would
think that it was a street performer
trying to be good yeah like it's
bumblebee but he's like you know like
instead of taking pictures with them
he's trying to stop [ __ ] yeah he's a big
he's a big boy yeah i would just run
from that guy big mofo he's big oh yeah
he's big dude are those painted on can
you type where's phoenix jones now
because we need him now more than ever i
know where he is there's so much crime
now but it's crazy because i feel like
the the police would arrest him faster
than the people he's trying to catch
yeah because they could find him yeah
right yeah that wouldn't happen in new
york dude you gotta
like that guy wouldn't be able to afford
living in new york
if you're a vigilante
you're tired at work
[Laughter]
oh yeah phoenix jones yeah he was the
leader
of the rain city superhero movement so
there was there was a couple see
on january 9 2020 jones was arrested for
allegedly settling silly molly
police allege that he and his accomplice
were also in possession of four grams of
coke
well they needed a little bit of
pick-me-ups for their late nights yeah
that's they needed to be wired while
they were fighting damn that's sad
rolling yeah yeah half at the time of
his life
man you can't be a criminal and a crime
fighter
or else you're gonna beat yourself up
this is like a real life kick ass it
really is yeah but i i don't remember if
he ever had any like confirmed like
foils where he like got the bad guy i
think most of these things were
to defuse people from fighting like he
would go and then like there's like a
diplomat yeah and then he's all just
like come on guys don't fight and then
that's so lame though like you gotta
wait for it to happen you know
like that's that must be so boring yeah
why don't you just beat them up because
you suspect they're criminals yeah like
minority report them oh [ __ ] you just
[ __ ] this person up because you're like
you're probably gonna commit a crime
yeah he looks sketchy he just profiles
everybody you a criminal
i'm waiting for the uh
vigilante it goes around whacking cops
oh [ __ ] oh no
yeah dude that sucks that happened to
phoenix jones well yeah
i don't know he had the heart of a crime
asian it's probably good that he's not
doing that [ __ ] anymore because i feel
like that's a sure-fire way of getting
killed
yeah but we need more vigilantes in
superhero outfits i think yeah i mean it
just looks cooler it's kind of sad that
that's what it feels like
is that him yeah it's him you like it
[ __ ]
you can get behind this guy
hell yeah
dude he looks scary why are you laughing
he's going to save us did he turn his
neck though how does he turn his head he
doesn't phoenix jones goes full torso
i think when he turns his neck then he's
just stares into the other side
it stays in place
i can't see it's like those magicians
with a rotating
i love head backdrop that they look so
stupid you look like he's about to like
admit like a secret plan we need to find
let me find out did phoenix jones ever
stop any crime let's see i like phoenix
jones man we need more we need we need
[ __ ] crime fighters i don't like the
drug deal like spider-man in this world
why don't like cops have their own
superheroes
yeah i mean they got swat and stuff why
don't they have like a superhero
division like robocop yeah
they should have that they gotta get
some robocops out in the street or the
punisher yeah or like a dexter this
wikipedia is pretty big
what the [ __ ] it's very extensive
because when i was at the uh khabib
connor fight i think they knew some [ __ ]
was gonna
pop off they had the craziest super cops
i've ever seen what's what do you
consider a super like a [ __ ] sick six
like 280 dude and i'm like these are
[ __ ] super cops these guys could
break up like if you needed a breakup
like a five-on-five fight yeah this
guy's gonna break it up yo super cop it
was it was a actual police police yeah
yeah he was like is in his outfit but
you could just tell like imagine the
rock
wearing a police uniform like there was
like in the front row there was like
four of them
i'm like every department needs some of
these guys yeah yeah yeah they just look
like they'll just
pick people like stop fighting and just
pick them up and separate some super
cops and sometimes we need less costs
more super cops
like instead of a hundred bag costs
we'll get like five super cops take care
of the precinct you know and they're
okay then they're okay with like socking
them up a couple of times
some super cops
if they steal some [ __ ] they can [ __ ]
suck them up and then i'm tired of these
dad cops we need some power forwards in
them
phoenix jones has actually done a pretty
good amount of [ __ ] really what it
wasn't he stopped a lot of crimes like
he's uh he's um he's been around the
world he's stopped some car thefts like
from happening he like
he's stopped people from driving drunk
when they're like oh that's like yeah
that's a good one that's underrated
outside
people are drunk yeah dude you're gonna
drive right now and then punch him in
the face but that's really how he did it
yeah he like he like threatened the guy
he was like no you're not getting in
that car this would be so if you get
stopped by that guy that must be so
embarrassing
i bet that guy's a [ __ ] tank though
huh i'll be like okay i won't drive and
then he's also he's also done things
like within the boundary of the law were
like and he sells meth like a guy was i
know a guy was stabbed and he followed
the suspect until the cops came so that
he'd be able to tell them where they are
like that's pretty good that's tight
like he's not trying to you know
be kick-ass 100 but he is like there
should be a gofundme for that guy
because this poor guy can't make a
living being a vigilante so we got to
sell [ __ ] molly maybe he was making
the cops look bad so they like you know
caught him inside they framed him
that's an easy thing to think i feel
like because why would he just sell
drugs if he's doing all these good
things wow what do you think his uh
win-loss record is in mma he's a
welterweight wow how many fights does he
have he's a welterweight yeah he's
pretty big he looks big though yeah it's
like a light heavyweight or something
maybe he cuts yeah he really
walks around like 190. maybe this is
when he was younger and he was actually
smaller seven three
he has one draw oh [ __ ] wow that's how
did you even think of that i just
guessed it seven wins three last dude
that's pretty remarkable the draft
[ __ ] me up we should have asked you
about fighting instead of passing it
he's pretty diverse too he got a
knockout four submissions this guy's
well-rounded oh yeah that's a true
what a beast yeah those are actually
this is the judge's fault so he actually
won all of them yeah damn he's
undefeated yeah he's actually undefeated
a free phoenix jungles bro
i think it's free
he's free already we gotta get him on
the show you gotta hit a phoenix jones
dude this guy has a bible of a wikipedia
yeah it's all his like things that he's
like stopped i think he writes his own
wikipedia
way
i didn't think of that that's funny
you